une normalisation des relations avec la
turquie c'est ce à quoi se prépare
l'union européenne à l'entâme de cette
nouvelle année si les sujets de discorde
entre bruxelles et ankara se sont
multipliées au cours des derniers mois
dans le sillage des attaques virulentes
bardot anna l'encontre de ses voisins
le ton a changé depuis le président turc
a même ouvert la porte la semaine
dernière un apaisement entre les deux
parties c'est dans ce cadre que mevlüt
cavusoglu
le ministre turc des affaires étrangères
s'est rendu à bruxelles ce jeudi pour y
rencontrer josep borrell mais 2020 a été
une année problématique en ce qui
concerne les relations entre la turquie
et l'union européenne
une volonté politique est apparu pour
créer une atmosphère plus positive à la
suite du sommet de l'union européenne en
décembre
nous avons eu l'occasion d'établir un
meilleur dialogue
preuve de la bonne volonté du
gouvernement turc
la proposition de pourparlers avec la
grèce à partir du 25 janvier au sujet
des explorations d'hydrocarbures en
méditerranée orientale
après les sanctions prononcées par l'ue
et la turquie a accepté de relancer le
dialogue après quatre ans d'impasse
une initiative remarquée et appréciée
côté européen
une autre bonne étape et la reprise
annoncée des pourparlers exploratoires
direct entre la turquie et la grèce ces
efforts doivent être maintenus les
intentions et les annonces doit être
traduite en initiative est un effort
salué mais avec tout de même quelques
réserves
ursula von der leyen présidente de la
commission européenne déclare attendre
des gestes crédibles sur le terrain une
condition préalable avant d'entamer les
discussions en vue de normaliser les
relations avec ankara